a highly contentious plan is underway in
Japan prime minister fumio Kita says
treated radioactive Wastewater from the
Fukushima nuclear plant could start to
be released into the Pacific Ocean on
Thursday
the governments will take responsibility
until the disposal of treated water is
completed even if it takes several
decades in order to safely complete the
decommissioning and release of the water
the decision comes after kishita Met
Executives from the Tokyo Electric Power
Company also known as tepico on Sunday
they reassured him about the safety of
the water discharge after most
radioactive elements have been removed
the tepco plan has been approved by the
UN nuclear Watchdog the international
atomic energy agency says it complies
with global safety standards around 1
million three hundred thousand tons of
stored water is due to go into the
Pacific over several decades the water
was used to cool the daiichi nuclear
reactors when they started to melt down
following the devastating earthquake and
tsunami 12 years ago but Engineers have
run out of space to store the Wastewater
hindering the decommissioning of the
power station cheetah faces a strong
opposition within the country Fukushima
fishermen who are still recovering after
the 2011 triple disaster for your
potential reputational damage
environment activists say tepco's data
is insufficient and the treated
radioactive Wastewater could harm marine
life and the entire population
dozens of protesters also made their
feelings known outside the prime
minister's office
pouring this wolf to them over the span
of 30 to 40 years we don't know how this
will affect us in the future and Japan
says that the plan is necessary because
it's run out of space I can't forgive
Japan for this
China South Korea and Pacific island
nations are also against the Japanese
plan
this blatantly transfers the risk of
nuclear contamination to the whole world
which is an extremely selfish and
irresponsible move despite the
controversy the Japanese government is
pressing on it's allocated 342 million
dollars to compensate Japanese fishermen
for any Financial damage caused to their
livelihoods
Hanukkah Montgomery Al Jazeera Tokyo